ce week end c'était la finale de la
ligue des champions qui se déroulait à
saint denis mais les journalistes
espagnols d'algérie kuito se sont rendus
à notre dame on ne sait pas trop
pourquoi
et si paris pour beaucoup c'est la ville
de l'amour de la tour eiffel des petits
trains qui passent devant le moulin
rouge bat l'envoyé spéciale d'al chéri
bhutto a découvert une autre facette de
la capitale ivoirienne où la gratte à
acheter du dollar atteint
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au
bâton
et oui les rues parisiennes sont
infestés de petits ratatouille pas
toujours très mignon
j - 786 avant le coup d'envoi des jeux
olympiques de paris 2024 786 jour ça on
est large pour le regard rassurez-vous
tout sera réglée au cordeau pour que
vive la magie du sport à paris de 1024
vous retrouverez les épreuves reines le
saut en hauteur les scream
le judo la boxe un des premiers moteurs
seront à votre disposition pour vous
rafraîchir gratuitement la france est
donc incapable d'organiser une finale de
ligue des champions la france est
incapable de filtrer le flux de
supporters qui arrive dans un stade un
soir de finale la france et ce pays où
l'arc de triomphe et saccagés ou les
black blocks cassent tout sur leur
passage les jours de manifestation et ou
les rodéos urbains sont glorifiés au
festival de cannes la douceur des
écharpes vous surprendra au point de ne
plus vouloir l'équité offert pour les
grands comme les petits tout ça dans la
plus belle ville du monde paris 2024
ouais 786 jours on a le temps de
s'adapter la france est ce pays où
l'hôpital public va mal ou l'école est
en difficulté ou la police la justice
déplore leur manque de moyens en même
temps que les français croule sous les
impôts des taxes le stade de france a
révélé une fois encore les manques de
l'état un état impuissant un état
déficient un état défaillant un état
fort avec les faibles et faible avec les
forts
s'est passé vraiment inadmissible et
incroyable en colère à cause de série là
nous là tout le monde est facilité tout
le monde est passé
pauvre france pauvre france je sais pas
de quoi on se plaint parce que là on a
été très bon dans tout ce qu'on sait
faire de mieux la grève le manque
d'organisation le manque d'anticipation
la naïveté et la mauvaise foi donc là on
était vraiment dans notre domaine
d'expertisé je suis très content je
reconnais mon pays donc
non mais ça m'a france
le contraire le contraire m'aurait
vraiment étonné c'est vrai que le truc
ne marchait pas en fait pourquoi parce
que comme eu énormément de faux billets
ça se bloque un moment c'est ça
aujourd'hui c'est exactement donc il y
avait il y avait un il y avait vraiment
une foule incroyable parce que un moyen
tellement de faux billets qui sont
passées que la machine le tourniquet se
bloque donc forcément voilà c'est ce
n'était plus possible de passer par les
passants tout et c'est jordi gentiment
qui me dit papa sans doute parce qu'il
voyait plus en plus de gens arrivent et
pour faire des selphy voilà les brigands
qui va dit passe en dessous comme ça au
moins jack ira plus vite c'est c'était
d'ailleurs la bonne solution en la
personne n'a dit dans une réunion
attention il ya karim benzema sur le
terrain et bien c'est simple c'est la
même personne n'a pensé à ça vous avez
raison je pense c'est aussi simple que
ça parce que s'il n'ya pas karim benzema
les cpu qui ne sont pas là et le real
tout simplement mais la semaine dernière
il ya une finale de coupe de france il
était pas on redémarre même avec une
nouvelle ministre bonsoir madame rim
abdoun malades merci d'être là ce soir
la ministre la dernière fois qu'il ya eu
autant d' enthousiasme dans cette salle
pour une ministre s'était françoise
nyssen la joconde victime d'un acte de
vandalisme de nombreux visiteurs du
louvre ont été témoins de la scène hier
un homme portant une perruque et se
déplace en fauteuil roulant s'est
approché du tableau sur lequel il a jeté
une part de gâteau le chef d'oeuvre de
léonard de vinci est intacte c'est la
vitrine blindée qui a tout pris
l'individu a ensuite jeté des pétales de
roses appréhendé par le service de
sécurité du musée il a revendiqué son
geste
les accus
je vois que vous à assise pas loin de
madame la présidente même juste à côté
de france télévisions delphine ernotte
bonsoir alors j'espère vous avez pas
trop discuter de la suppression de la
redevance
l'ambiance est bonne voie la meilleure
note non mais c'est vrai que c'est
toujours drôle quand on est un petit peu
a découvert qu'on veut passer une soirée
de détente au théâtre on s'assoit et
l'hymne à cô té il ya son banquier